[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi and
welcome to episode number
20 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Francesc Campoy and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Francesc.
How you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty
good, pretty good.
Very excited about
the topic today,
even though it's not
my favorite topic.
MARK MANDEL: So we're
not talking about Go.
It's very true.
We're going to be talking
about Node and JavaScript.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, we're going
to be talking
Node.js on the Cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Yep, yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We got
actually Justin Beckwith,
Product Manager for Google
Cloud Platform that specializes
among all the things
on Node.js, so we're
going to have him talking about
why you should use-- I'm not
going to say you
should use Node.js,
but like why you could use
Node.js in Google Cloud
Platform.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I would say
if Node.js and JavaScript is
your product of choice--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If it's your
thing, we have things for you.
MARK MANDEL: If it's your
programming language of choice,
we have a lot of
really cool stuff
that we're going to talk about
and a lot of cool partnerships
and sorts of other fun stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And then
at the end of the episode,
we're going to be talking
a little bit about Question
of the Week on Bigtable.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
But before that, let's talk a
little bit about the cool thing
of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
we had a couple
of really nice announcements
about Cloud Datastore,
actually.
That's a product that's been
around for quite a long while,
but it's getting some love,
which I'm very happy to see.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it's been there.
Probably it's one of all
the solutions that we have,
it came with Google App
Engine, I'm assuming.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I assume so too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, pretty
old, but still very good.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so if you
aren't familiar with Datastore,
it's our NoSQL data store.
The cool thing
about it though is
it doesn't really matter how
much data you put inside it.
The read and write
times stay the same
and it shards and replicates for
you, which is pretty awesome.
It's very, very, very powerful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it works
very well with App Engine.
Basically, they both scale
from zero to whatever
you want very, very well.
It scales on traffic,
scales on data.
You don't have to do anything.
It's completely manged, so
it's a very, very sweet project
to use.
MARK MANDEL: But one
of things I like to see
is the pricing
structure for Datastore
before, let's just say
it was complicated.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
was, yeah, complex.
MARK MANDEL: Complex.
It was fun.
It would have been really
difficult to work out exactly
what you need to do up front.
It wasn't-- yeah, it was tricky.
It was definitely tricky.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So we fixed that.
MARK MANDEL: We fixed it.
We just fixed it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Well, not us but--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
how does it work now?
MARK MANDEL: So now
it's far, far simpler.
Simply put, if you are
going to write something,
it is simply based on that
write for that entity.
You no longer have to worry
about indexes or anything
like that.
Reads it the same.
The cost is per entity.
And deletes are exactly the same
in that it's just per entity.
You'll be charged for a single
delete operation per entity,
and we've got flat rates
for all of those now.
So for you to work out exactly
what those sort of costs
are going to be upfront,
much, much easier.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
And that also translates
into in most use cases,
you're going to end up
paying less, which is great.
MARK MANDEL: Which is great.
You don't have to worry as
much about your indexes.
Cost savings are great.
Make life a lot easier
for you to develop those.
You don't have to
like micro-manage
all of these things so that
you can keep your costs down.
We want to make that happy
and a good place for you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
just write the code
that you think you should
write and then everything
should just work with and adapt
to the use case you're doing.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Now we also have one other
thing for Datastore as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Do we?
MARK MANDEL: We do.
So if you're interacting with
Datastore, say particularly
outside of App Engine,
we released some new APIs
to make that a
little bit faster.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
How is that a little be faster?
How did we make that?
How did we do it?
MARK MANDEL: So we have
a new v1beta3 version
of the Datastore API.
The read latencies on
that-- we will have links
to the graphs on
the show notes--
but significant
performance improvements
is the exact quote
I'm looking at.
The red line is much
shorter than the blue line
in the graphs, which I think
makes it better, which is good.
So not only are we trying to
make things simpler for you,
cheaper for you, but also
faster for you as well,
if that's what
you're looking for.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
And something that I really
like is that that also
includes-- so
there's a JSON API,
but there's also a
Protocol Buffers in gRPC.
MARK MANDEL: Had to be there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
We want it to be
faster, so of course.
So yeah, if you have some little
processes running somewhere
where you want to have
something working really
fast to store data,
gRPC over Datastore
and that's pretty much it.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
So why don't we go to our
main content for today
and let's go talk with Justin.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds
great let's do that.
Thanks so much to
Justin Beckwith
for joining us for this
wonderful evening today.
Justin, how are you doing?
JUSTIN BECKWITH:
I'm doing fantastic.
How are you guys doing?
MARK MANDEL: Pretty good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Doing great.
MARK MANDEL: Yup.
So for those who
haven't met you,
haven't had the chance to be
in the presence of your very
effervescent personality, why
don't you tell us a little bit
about yourself, what
you do here at Google,
all that sort of good stuff?
JUSTIN BECKWITH: Absolutely.
So my name's Justin Beckwith.
I'm a Product Manager
here at Google,
and primarily, I have
the chance to work
on the developer experience
for Google App Engine.
And it's a really fun gig.
I get to dig deep
into technologies,
deep into Node.js, PHP, Python,
Ruby, just about anything,
and I get to help
influence what it's
like for developers to walk
up to our platform and use it,
hopefully making it
a little bit easier.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Now I believe you have a
bit of a focus on Node.js.
Is that correct?
JUSTIN BECKWITH: Yeah.
It's been a huge, huge couple
of months for us on Node.js.
We just shipped the beta of the
Node.js runtime on App Engine,
so I've been doing a lot
of JavaScript these days.
MARK MANDEL: Whole
lot of JavaScript.
Excellent.
OK so I guess the first question
I ask is like, why Node.js?
You seem to being doing a lot
of work there, seems to be,
obviously, you're finding
it quite important.
What's the reasoning there?
What are we doing?
JUSTIN BECKWITH: Yeah, so there
are a lot of great reasons
to use Node.js.
I think the big thing
that first attracted me
to the platform and
the first development
team I was on that
started using it,
it was about taking advantage
of a single language
both for our front end
and our back end code.
So we had spent years
and years and years
building up this--
building up a lot of muscle
on using JavaScript for
front end web applications.
And all of a sudden
you go to the back end
and you had to go completely
different language,
different package
manager, different
build system, different
libraries, the whole thing.
I think the big
beauty of Node.js
is that you learn one
language, one ecosystem.
You know, npm is getting huge.
And now I can use
those skills front end,
back end, services, web
applications, APIs, UI,
doesn't matter.
It works the whole
way across the stack.
For me, I think that's the most
attractive quality of Node.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
sounds very good.
Also so I don't do
Node.js, but I'm
very happy that Google is
coming a little bit more
to the community of Node.js
because there is actually
a lot of people outside
that are doing it.
So it's a little bit
following the philosophy
of go where the developers are.
Developers are doing a lot
of Node, so that's great.
The next question is about--
so yeah OK, so why Google?
Like Node.js is very cool.
There's a lot of people
that are doing it,
but what is the relationship
between Google and Node.js?
JUSTIN BECKWITH:
Yeah, so we have
a bit of an interesting
history here actually.
Node.js started happening
around, I want to say it
was 2009 when it
started getting built.
And it's built on top of V8,
the JavaScript execution engine
that's part of Google Chrome.
So we spent all of these years
building up all this expertise
on optimizing JavaScript,
making it run as fast as humanly
possible in web browsers,
and then a group of folks
over at Join started building
and making it fast for running
on the server side as well.
And for a couple of years,
you know, here at Google,
we have a set of
languages that we focus on
and JavaScript on
the server side
traditionally hasn't
been one of them.
And so that effort kind
of went on in parallel.
And really, I think over the
last few years, especially
this year, as you
Node.js has gotten closer
to being more viable for
enterprise application
development, we're starting to
get a little bit more involved.
We sort of sat aside and let
this thing develop on its own
and now we're trying to
dig in and we're trying
to be a help to the community.
I think that you're
starting to see
a lot more large corporations
take a bet on Node.js,
big companies.
There's a LTS support
model now in place,
so you know that with
the latest versions,
you're going to get 18 months
of backward compatibility
and security patches.
Kind of in my mind, I think
the big thing that's shifted
is it's starting to get real.
I think at first,
it was great if you
were building small-time
web applications,
startups, you needed to
do something quickly,
it was a popular choice.
But now we can use this to
build real web applications.
It's actually harder
to find companies
that aren't using
Node at this stage
if they're doing
web development.
MARK MANDEL: Cool
so-- all right.
So obviously yeah, we're
kind of keen on Node.
That's great.
But what does the
developer experience look
like right now
for wanting to use
Node on Google Cloud Platform?
Like what products does
it sort of work with
or what does that flow look like
if I'm going to sit down and be
like, I want to right Node now?
JUSTIN BECKWITH: Sure, so there
are a couple of options there.
The one that almost
everyone is used to,
if you wanted to set
up a virtual machine
and just bring your code and
set up Node.js and run it,
of course that's going
to work same as it would
any other cloud provider.
I think the things that
make running Node.js
in Google Cloud interesting,
unique, and useful
are both Google
Container Engine, which
is the hosted
version of Kubernetes
for running Docker
containers at scale,
and then, of course, App Engine.
So I'll start with
App Engine then
we can talk a little
bit about Kubernetes.
With App Engine, it's just sort
of the idea is you show up,
you bring your code,
and we run it for you.
We scale it.
You push it to us and we sort
of take care of the rest.
And if you want to dig
in and customize it,
at the end of the day,
all we're really doing
is running Docker
containers for you.
So if you want to go
customize the image,
install something that you want
on top of the operating system,
something like ImageMagick,
FFmpeg, that sort of thing,
you can just sort of take over
and define what the runtime is
going to look like.
But at the end of the day, the
idea is you bring the code,
we run it.
MARK MANDEL: So do we like--
I mean, obviously, we're
sounding like-- we
said we released
beta support for Node.js.
Like what does
that actually mean?
You said we can just
take the code and run it.
What does that actually
end up looking like?
JUSTIN BECKWITH: Sure, so
when you come to the platform
after you do the sign up,
you use the Cloud SDK.
You can run-- you build
your web application,
have it inside a directory,
run gcloud app deploy.
And then after
that, you're going
to get a website running
on an appspot domain.
So you would
getmyapplication.appspot.com.
And that's going
to scale up to, I
think by default, somewhere
between 2 and 20 instances
running on our platform.
But really what
the beta was about
was just kind of signifying
that all the pieces that come
to building a
Node.js application,
it actually goes beyond
what's in App Engine.
And I think all those pieces
are falling into place.
So that's-- the Docker image
that we use to run your app,
that's now open source
on GitHub, Node.js,
Docker and we publish
that out to GCRIO.
We have the gcloud
npm module is actually
a really important
piece of this.
So this is the npm module
that provides access
to all of the APIs
and services-- things
like BigQuery, Bigtable,
Cloud Vision API.
We're starting to work
on the Speech API, all
of this cool stuff we got
to announce last week,
or I guess now two
weeks ago, at GCP Next.
And finally logging
integration-- what is it
like to emit logs
from the platform
and have an easy way
to get access to those?
Error Reporting--
just sort of all
of these things that
sit around the platform
and aren't necessarily
running your code,
but the things that are
really important when it's
time to build your application,
monitor it, diagnose it, all
those sorts of bits.
MARK MANDEL: So
really we've got--
we've got all the tools
now to build whatever
it is you need to use using
all the pieces of our platform.
And they may not necessarily
have been there before,
but they're there now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
There's something that
I wanted to mention,
which is so I recently watched
your talk at GCP Next, which
was really awesome.
Congratulations on that.
JUSTIN BECKWITH: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
really loved the demo.
That nuclear hat--
that was really cool.
But one of the things
that you showed
was how to basically
move from App Engine
to Container Engine
in a very easy way.
Could you talk a little
bit more about that?
Because I thought it
was very interesting.
JUSTIN BECKWITH: Yeah.
I think that's
actually the best part
about App Engine right now.
We started off as this
ecosystem was a little bit
closed off, a
little bit-- vendor
specific APIs,
that sort of thing.
And it's now reached a point
where really what we're doing
is creating an abstraction
that makes it easier
to run Docker containers.
So if you're not
familiar with Docker,
you don't need to know
anything about it.
You just bring in
the code and it runs.
But if you are
familiar with Docker
and if you already have
a workflow for handling
this kind of work,
then what you can do
is just run a single
command-- gcloud preview
app gen-config --custom.
We can get some
resources, I'm sure,
after this for those who are
interested in in doing it.
And it's going to generate the
Docker file that we use inside
of the runtime when we run
it on top of App Engine.
So after that, if you want
to run on top of Kubernetes,
all you have to do is
stand up your cluster,
run Docker Build to build
your Docker image that
has your application
code, and then you
can deploy, just like you
would any other Docker
container into Kubernetes.
So it's really flexible
up and down the stack.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is very cool.
That also means that you can
run the container directly
in your machine, right?
JUSTIN BECKWITH:
Yeah, absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is very nice.
MARK MANDEL: That's really cool.
So you can basically
start with Managed VMs
sort of just to get you
going, get you up and running,
and then as you need
more flexibility,
you need to sort of
run down that computer
is a continuum spectrum we've
sort of talked about before.
You've got that option
to just pick up and move.
That's very powerful.
JUSTIN BECKWITH: I think
where that really shines
is where you want to
extend beyond what's
in a common Node.js application.
So like I mentioned, stuff like
ImageMagick, FFmpeg, or let's
say you want to
be able to support
multiple languages inside of
the same image at the same time.
You can completely take that
thing over, install whatever
you want on it, and then it
can run either an App Engine
with the automatic
scaling and management,
or over on Kubernetes
if you need the control.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So I think we should
probably talk a little bit
about the elf in the room,
considering we're talking
about JavaScript, so Parse.
Let's talk about Parse.
How does our strategy
around that sort of fit?
We keep getting it at events.
People will come up to
us and they're like,
oh so can I run my Parse code
on like Google Cloud Platform
and what does that look like?
What do I do?
JUSTIN BECKWITH:
Yeah, this is one
of those things we get a lot.
It especially makes
it interesting
the fact that we
have Firebase, right,
and Firebase base
is owned by Google
and runs on Google Cloud now.
So when you start
talking about Parse,
then everything gets a
little bit interesting.
But yeah, we support--
obviously, we support both.
One of the great things that
Facebook did-- I was actually
really, really impressed by
this-- when they announced
that they were going to stop
working on Parse as a platform,
as a service, they
right out of the gate
announced that they were
open sourcing the components,
made everything
available to developers,
and they did that as
a Node.js application.
So if you want to go run Parse
Server today, if you've already
built an app and you've
deployed it to Parse
and you're looking for
a way to get that off
of Facebook as they start
to turn the service down,
they've made it really
easy to take and run
that on other platforms.
And of course one
of the platforms
where that's going
to run is going
to be on Google App Engine.
So we have some samples.
We have some
documentation out there.
We did a blog post.
Really, getting started
this thing is pretty simple.
You just need to deploy
the Parse Server Node.js
application, stand
up MongoDB instance.
We used Mongo labs, I think,
for our sample when we did this.
And then it's pretty
easy to migrate.
MARK MANDEL: So
that's pretty cool.
I guess that's almost
testament as well
to the work that's
gone into making
the beta support for Node.js,
that you can take something
like the Parse open source
framework and be like,
OK, this isn't so bad.
We just got to kind of
write the documentation
to make this happen.
JUSTIN BECKWITH: Yeah, it's
kind of a funny story actually.
When we first read the news
that this was happening,
I think it was about
2:00, and I went over
to Jason Dobry, who's one
of the platform engineers
that works on Node.js with us.
He's built a lot of
the documentation,
a lot of the samples, a lot
of the code we have out there
on GitHub.
And we just kind
of casually started
talking about, what would
it take to get this up
and running?
And I expected to come back
like later in the evening
and take a look at it.
An hour later, I got an
email from him saying
that he had the sample already.
He had a pull request
on GitHub ready to go.
So it was over the course
of an hour, he had that.
An hour later, we
had a blog post.
An hour after that,
there was documentation.
And the evening that
it was announced,
we had everything
up and running,
so it's really a testament
to how great the Facebook
guys did in making
this stuff easily
portable on other platform,
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
Also I guess it's also testament
to how App Engine is not
vendor-locked, as
people tend to say.
You can get any code and
just run it there directly.
That is very cool.
JUSTIN BECKWITH: Yeah, it's
a big change from where
we were back in 2008, you know?
App Engine has been around for
a long time and a lot of things
have changed.
Pretty much any
npm module you want
to use for Node.js, any
web server, anything,
you just show up and, within
reason, we can run it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
As part of your talk, if I
remember correctly-- or maybe
there was a different talk
and I'm mixing things--
but I think that you
had someone else talking
about Node.js for companies.
JUSTIN BECKWITH: Yeah,
so that was actually
during the GCP Next talk,
and I had Joe McCann, who's
the CEO of NodeSource, a company
that does enterprise Node.js,
up on stage talking with us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There were
some announcements there.
Maybe you could share with us?
JUSTIN BECKWITH: Yeah.
So the big thing that we
wanted to do announce at Next
was just that we formed a
partnership with NodeSource.
Source And what that
means is that we're
able to take the enterprise
distribution of Node.js
that they've built and
that they support, along
with all the tooling
in their ecosystem,
and easily run that on
Google Cloud Platform.
So today, really
what that means is
it's a separate
distribution of Node that
comes with performance
analysis tools that
make it easy to debug things
like memory leaks, high CPU
utilization, produces
flame graphs,
a variety of great
visualizations to help dig in
and really, really
understand what's
happening with Node.js
processes in the event
they start to run amok,
as on occasion they do.
MARK MANDEL: OK so
I guess that means
we've got some stuff there that
people can just kind of get up
with and just run
with from NodeSource
that they're able to
run on our platform
just like they would normally?
JUSTIN BECKWITH:
Yeah, absolutely.
Right now most of
the offering is
centered around Compute Engine,
but we're working really
hard to bring that to the
other layers of the stack,
down through Container Engine
and App Engine eventually
as well.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So I'm actually quite
curious as well.
Obviously, you've
some experience
working with Node developers
here on our platform.
What's the coolest
project you've
seen of people building stuff
with Node on anything on Google
Cloud Platform?
JUSTIN BECKWITH: Wow, anything
on the Google Cloud Platform
so far?
MARK MANDEL: With Node.
With Node.
Just to narrow it slightly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Other than
making a nuclear cap turn.
See, I thought that
was pretty much it,
connecting it to little bits.
You know, it has
everything, right?
It's got IoT.
It's got WebSockets.
It's got Node.
It was end to end
on the platform.
MARK MANDEL: Well so actually
we'll back track for a second.
We've talked a little
about your presentation.
For those people who
haven't seen this,
do you want to talk
us through the demo
you had and then
maybe we'll come back
to our original question?
JUSTIN BECKWITH: Sure,
so it was just a few
demos-- some serious, some
just for fun, quite honestly,
because they amused me-- but all
with the idea of showing of how
to use Node.js on our platform.
So the first one we did was
with the Cloud Vision API.
We did a little
analysis of Reddit.
Actually, went on r/aww.
We were detecting
images on Reddit
to figure out if they were
dogs or cats, putting them
in the right category, and
kind of doing real time data
analytics on stage.
That one that was fun.
I was really,
really worried when
I was doing that demo that
Reddit was going to go down
and I was going to be
left standing there
with an empty webpage,
but it all worked out.
And then the last demo that
we started put together
was on using littleBits.
littleBits are small, composable
electronic building blocks,
usually for kids or
for the young at heart,
and they have this thing
called a cloudBit that
let's you connect
them to the internet.
So we started playing
around with those
and seeing what it would be
like to connect it to Node.js
on Google Cloud Platform.
And I think during that, there
was too much interference
in the room and not
everything tied together
the way I would have liked,
but it was still pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And the final result
was a twirling propeller
on your nuclear hat?
JUSTIN BECKWITH: Oh yeah.
It played music.
It twirled the hat.
It did everything.
It was-- lots of engineering
manpower going into that hat.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Definitely
worth the effort.
MARK MANDEL: That's great.
OK, cool.
So there's a bunch of work
going into Node.js Google Cloud
Platform.
Are you able to hint at
anything, like what's upcoming,
what things should
people expect, you know,
that sort of good stuff?
JUSTIN BECKWITH:
Yeah, absolutely.
So phase one for us was kind of
going and making all this stuff
run great on Google
Cloud Platform.
So we talked about Trace
and Debug and App Engine
and the integration with
NodeSource and all the fun
stuff around that.
I think the next step is
actually integrating ourselves
more closely with Node.js
as an organization
and as an underlying technology.
So we've built up
all these years,
as I mentioned, years of
muscle and making JavaScript
work great on the web browser.
Well the next step is to
actually dig in and help make
it run better on the server.
I don't think that
we've done as much
there as we've always wanted
to in the early days of Node.
And I think we could have
a huge impact doing things
like making the developer
tooling in Chrome
work better with Node.js,
make the debugging
story a little bit
easier, make the tooling
story a little bit better,
improve the performance.
One of the things that we've
done to actually kick off
this next stage of work, now
that we're past the beta,
is we've actually just recently
joined the Node.js foundation,
and that's a group that's
responsible for driving Node.js
as a technology forward--
not just on Google Cloud,
but making Node better
for developers everywhere.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
That actually shows
a lot of commitment
from Google, being
part of it, really.
But what else could people
working with Node.js
expect to see soon on
Google Cloud Platform?
We have a bunch of APIs and
they can run on App Engine.
It's beta.
Could tell us a
little bit more about
is there any specific
roadmap that you could share?
You're a product manager, so
maybe you have that power.
JUSTIN BECKWITH:
Yeah, absolutely.
I think the biggest
things you're
going to see from
us moving forward
are better API support
for all the cool services.
So we announced a
lot of great stuff
at GCP Next, things like Cloud
ML, the Google Cloud Speech
API.
As we start to turn out more
and more of these services,
then we have to
expose meaningful APIs
for Node developers-- not
just on Google Cloud Platform,
but if you want to take
advantage of these APIs
from your own data centers, from
other clouds, we don't care.
However you want to do it,
we want to kind of open up
these sort of, I like to call
them the Google Cloud magic
APIs, all the stuff that
does machine learning.
We're going to be
spending a lot of time
there, improving those
APIs and getting them
in front of everyone.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
We're pretty much out
of time, but is there
anything else that you
would like to mention
that we didn't have time to?
JUSTIN BECKWITH:
Yeah, the big thing
is just we love
JavaScript here at Google.
We love the web.
We like connecting
things to the internet
and we like running services.
And we're committed to
making Google Cloud the best
place to run
Node.js applications
and we're committed to
making Node.js itself better.
So if you're looking for a place
to bring your code, come to us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Well
thank you so much,
Justin, for spending
the time with us.
We really appreciate it.
JUSTIN BECKWITH: All right.
Thanks a lot, guys.
This was fun.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks a lot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool,
thanks again to Justin
for such an awesome
conversation-- learned a lot,
had lots of fun.
We will have a bunch
of links in the show
notes to all the little
resources that he mentioned,
the talk where you can see
him wearing a nuclear hat that
turns around, so lots of fun.
Before we finish
for today, let's
talk about the
Question of the Week.
We said it was a Bigtable,
but why don't you, Mark,
tell us a little bit
about the question itself?
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So we got a nice
email from a gentleman
by the name of Michael McKenzie.
His question is,
I think Bigtable
could be used in one of
my personal projects,
but I do not know
where to start.
He's actually read the
Google paper on it.
Good for him.
That's a job well done.
However, I find myself a bit
lost in fully understanding
how to get going.
That said, do you have
any recommendations
of simple apps or
projects one can
get acquainted with Bigtable?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: So I feel like this
is kind of like a two-parter,
actually.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think
that the first part
is when you say you're
planning on using it
for personal
projects, I could say,
think about it twice, unless
your personal projects have
an amazing traffic
and you really
need the throughput
that Bigtable can offer.
I could say that maybe
Datastore is the place to be.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I'd probably almost
look at it as well from
like personal projects.
Bigtable can be expensive.
We turn around and
say, yeah, if you
want a rather large amount
of data for that cost savings
to kind of kick in.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If your
personal project requires
something like 1 million
operations per second, yes,
go for it.
But if you're around
one per second,
probably Bigtable is
a little bit overkill.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, probably.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
But if you actually
want to learn more
about Bigtable,
I think that reading the paper
is a very, very good step--
maybe overkill too.
It's not probably the
best place to start
if you want to understand
more, but there's actually
all the documentation.
We also have a bunch of
sample projects on GitHub.
So that's on github.com/googl
ecloudplatform/c
loud-bigtable-samples, I think.
But we'll have the links to
those projects on the show
notes.
And in one of
those examples, you
would actually be able
to see that there's
a tool called Quickstart.
And Quickstart is
basically a Java tool
that allows you to use
Bigtable from the command line.
So you can create tables.
You can insert data.
You can read from it.
So you can basically
get a little bit
of an idea of how Bigtable
actually works and then you
can start playing with it.
Also, it's cool because
if you have a lot of data,
you can also see how
incredibly fast it works.
But if you're not a
Java guy, like me,
and you think that Maven is
very hard to understand-- which,
if you ask me, it is.
Also, XML?
Come on.
But there's actually
another tool
that I ended up
using personally,
which is called CBT.
That stands for Cloud
Bigtable, and it's read and go.
So basically you can
just install it directly
or I think that
there's distribution
binaries for Windows and
Mac and Linux and whatever.
And then you just run it because
you don't need anything else
because it's just a
self-maintained binary,
so that's cool.
MARK MANDEL: Not that
you're biased in any way,
shape, or form.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Absolutely not.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Absolutely not.
OK cool.
So yeah, if you want to
get started with Bigtable,
there's no reason why you
couldn't fire up a node
and sort of run it
within the trial period
for like a short period
or something like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Three nodes.
MARK MANDEL: Three nodes, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is the minimum.
MARK MANDEL: That is the
minimum, three nodes.
That's totally true.
But definitely shut that down
again before you're finished.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah.
I mean I think it's
a very nice way
to understand the power of the
Cloud, but at the same time,
if you try for a
personal project,
probably Datastore is
a good place to be.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I guess if you're
going to be running
that long term,
Datastore makes a lot of sense.
If you're going to do like a
few little bits and pieces,
you could run it
for a little bit
and then turn it back off again.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Well thank you so much, Mark.
Before we finish, what are
your plans for next week?
MARK MANDEL: Next week?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Or next weeks?
MARK MANDEL: Next weeks?
I don't know.
I actually think I'm just
going to be hanging out
in San Francisco writing some
content the next few weeks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
MARK MANDEL: How about yourself?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well
I'm actually going to be,
at the end of the month,
I will go to Budapest--
my first time going there,
very excited-- to be
talking about Go at Craft Conf.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, we're going
to have some other people
from the advocacy team.
Kelsey Hightower will be there,
also talking about Kubernetes.
So I think it's going to be
a very, very good conference.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Sounds like a lot of fun.
Brilliant.
Well, thank you so much for
joining me yet again, Francesc.
I really appreciate it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you
so much for being here too.
And talk to you next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]